hi guys I'm here with Max Brooks author
of Harlem Hellfighters his baseball
onesie and Zombie Survival Guide so
great to see you thank you so much for
coming so I wanted to talk to you more
about the book we talked about a little
bit on the show but it's great and if
you haven't picked it up you should it's
super informative very well researched
and obviously I enjoyed it and I just
want to ask you so this is a story
you've been very interested in for a
long time and I was wondering how on
earth did you narrow it down to figure
out what you wanted to include you know
I think that is the challenge when
anyone tries to tell fictionalized story
is how much do you include in the time
to be God because you could include
everything and it would be ninjas yeah
and I thought I would keep it short on
purpose because I want young people to
read it the attention span young people
have I figured you know don't intimidate
I remember when I was a kid and had
these giant bookshelf that me and my
there was one panel that was just
stunning and upsetting to me it was a
Jack Johnson Oh a guy being born if I
shale that actually is what really
happens when a high-explosive shell hits
them in your body it's called
hydrostatic shock what happens is when a
shell explodes it usually kills by
shrapnel pieces of metal flying over but
sometimes if it's closer to you the
explosion is close enough the energy
released by the explosion has to be
absorbed by something physics and it's
absorbed by you and it's absorbed by the
water in your body that's so I literally
blow the flesh right off your bones I
feel like now we're in this we're at the
stage where everything is kind of
everyone's accepted that drones are a
thing and everything feels more war
feels more personal now so reading
something like this which is fine if you
we're just find if you're the ones
firing the drums it's pretty personal
right exactly oh here it is yeah this is
a this is a frame that's a
high-explosive shell when it lands next
to a human body so basically ladies and
gentlemen Europeans would love you to
believe that they are the pinnacle of
civilization the Renaissance there
yeah they're also this thanks Europe
right so full panel I turned the page
and I just I had to put it down for a
second well you know I actually got I
got did you really yeah because grandma
said you know if you do the violence
this graphically it may not be an
educational tool like schools may not
want this and I said look this is not
fortuitous I'm not putting violence in
there because it's quits on a Tarantino
movie I'm putting the violence in here
because this is exactly based on real
research this is what happened in the
Great War and we need to acknowledge
that and it's not like every other panel
is that you definitely saved it for no
it didn't I don't know what impact it
has to be used in the important moment
and it's also a newsroom and that kind
of carnage needs to be sure so one of
the reasons why you wrote this book and
one of the reasons why I'm so glad this
book is around is because the story
hasn't been told even though this is one
of things the Hellfighters are one of
the most incredible accomplished
regiments the world and yet no one knows
and I think that's important to note you
know they're they're all oh yeah African
Americans have fought in every war but
not every unit how to stellar combat
read some of them should be commended
just because they fought racism alone is
about that I mean yes that alone they
should get medals for for how horribly
African Americans were treated but not
only that this unit just no matter what
color was an amazing unit fought longer
more days why the other more time in
combat that's any other American unit
the whole unit one the pas de guerre
they brought jazz tonight with James
researchers band they but just as
friends yeah lot of snow just ironic
considering the French tell us we have
no culture sure so just have this shoot
up in white we don't know that right you
know there would have been movies
made from the 20s onward about the heart
this must've been incredibly frustrating
for you to try and get this made in that
well the irony is I wrote it as a movie
script in the 90s before I was born
nobody wanted it and the barber he told
me not to give up really Barberton said
there's a lot of you know when you're a
dyslexic kid you don't do well in school
and the guy from Reading Rainbow tells
you that your script is good yes when
commander Geordi LaForge says you've
done your homework you stick with it
so I thought you know what a comic book
is a great way to television without
worrying about college I mean it's
basically a storyboard so yeah that's
right that I can the irony is two weeks
work came out we got a movie Will
Smith's company that they want me to
write the first draft the script all
right one last question so that actually
brings me to see you've got an
incredible response where you have a
blurb who Spike Lee Cornel West is
linked in the back of our Burton spike I
thought was gonna crucify me really
focus we know spikes not shy about his
opinion right no I don't think anyone
that's I said in my my beautiful wife I
said in oh honey you know who's gonna
come after me about this you know who's
gonna say who does this man think
who's writing our story right I mean
that's that's a concern right that's a
huge concern so we don't want to be
appropriating someone else's say sorry
but you want to tell it but you want to
be and nobody was telling you what I
thought spike was I thought he was gonna
easily come after me and he called me
and he said I'd love to me
met with them he goes listen I don't
care who makes this I don't care how it
gets made you what a great story needs
to be told I was that only the guy and
by the way get on the buses with my
favorite ladies that's great well thank
you so much everyone who gets on the
buns you can mark it up if you want